same thing for lamella ball who was such  an eye opener in the first half  with 13 points  gilges alexander set shot from behind  the arc  three-pointer for sga that's  [Music]  one out of two for hill  bottom of the whale devante finally hits  one out of two  hornets in a hurry miles clean look  got it it's a one possession game  hayward hornets down four big  opportunity  miles bridges it's a two-point  game  devonte finds milestone  no timeouts remaining for oklahoma city  hornets have one  gilded alexander long two  oh goodness shea gil just alexander  good cross over and then stops without i  think he wanted to get to the rim  but the crossover  got cody such off balance he gave him  too much space he had to take that shot  [Applause]